yo what's up everybody mad that we do
here with another fallout 4 video now in
this video I'm going to be showing you
guys how to get an infinite supply of
purified water and as a result an
infinite supply of caps and also you can
use those infinite supply of water as
aid so you have infinite healing and aid
so what you're going to want to do is
get a lot of water purifiers hopefully
you're specifically you really want the
industrial water purifiers they are the
biggest ones they do take 5 power each
however these are going to produce the
most water so what you're going to want
to do is get as most water production as
you can you can see I have 160 I do need
a buff of my defense and defense should
be proud a food plus water but this
method will allow me to do that so what
you're going to do is get a lot of water
generation and you want to do this
because if you have a lot of excess
water or food generation the excess
water food gets stored in the under the
aid section in your workshop as you can
see there's a hundred twenty-one
purified water all valued at twenty caps
now what you want to do is sell all of
this water I made vendors in my town
because I make enough water where I'd
come over encumbered so I can't fast
travel so having settlers traders here
in my town is the best method for me to
do this you do need local leader to
build these however I would say it's
definitely worth it i do think it's
really good perk and also it's good for
this because it lets you do this method
and also they just make you money in
general so you know get to these
settlers in the trading post and you're
just going to sell all you purified
water i have a lot of general stores
because general stores have a lot of
junk so i can buy the junk and then use
that to build up my settlement more such
as make more water purifiers or make
defenses because my defense should be
higher and yeah and you can also use all
of this water as eight it's purified
water is a pretty good healing source it
does take up some weight and especially
if you have a hundred and twenty one
it's going to take a lot of weight but
it is really good a really good healing
source since i think it deals like 20 or
40 and that's pretty good and very very
low radiation for the amount so it's
like yeah 40 help it that's pretty good
so yeah that's basically the entire
thing one thing i do want to note is
that when you make when you get the wall
into the workshop it it isn't really
cumulative it'll always stay at around
the same pace so if you like for me it's
always between 90 and 100 s like 919
like 120 121 as you can see in this
video if I leave and wait for like a
week of playtime and I come back it'll
still be at like around 100 it because
they just I guess they just throw out
the super excess water they only keep a
little bit of it and if I make more
water generators i'll probably have a
higher amount every time I come back so
it won't stack up unfortunately however
it's still it's still pretty easy to do
this so because I've enjoyed this quick
little guide on how to make infinite
calves infinite aid and infinite water
in fallout 4 and yeah if you had like
this make sure you check out more of my
channels I have a lot of fallout 4
content there and I will be continuing
to post a lot of fallout for content and
yeah hope you guys have enjoyed this I
appreciate you watching a lot and yeah
peace out
you